each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so today we're pleased to have
professor Alexandra boulder Ava visiting
us from Georgia Institute of Technology
and she will speak about deterministic
and efficiently searchable encryption
thank you thank you very much Kristen ah
can you hear me well is the mic on okay
good and thank you very much for
inviting me here I changed a little bit
the title and the talk just slightly
from what was announced and the abstract
I hope it's okay I included some new and
probably more applied things so and this
talk is based on several works i did
jointly with mahir belarius search for
her and my student Adam O'Neil these are
the talks which I will cover mostly but
if i have time i hope i will i will also
include some other things which were
done together with students at Georgia
Tech googors amanha tedious nay
Nietzsche net and Yuna Lee it was
actually visiting postdoc okay so the
plan of my talk I'll tell you about the
focus and motivation for looking at
these things then we'll talk about
problem of defining security for
deterministic encryption and why it's a
problem then we'll see several very
efficient and secure constructions some
will be in the random Oracle model and
then we'll see other constructions which
are slightly less efficient well some of
the more plus diffusion but they're
secure without relying on the random
Oracle model and we'll see some general
constructions and extended general
constructions and we'll discuss their
specific
instantiation and finally we'll talk
about more general primitives
efficiently sociable encryption which
doesn't have to be deterministic and
finally we'll discuss the problem of
deterministic encryption and the
symmetric is setting because most of the
talk is going to focus on the public key
a symmetric key setting and i also want
to talk about more flexible database
queries and encryption schemes designed
specifically for this problem okay so
let's go off with this we'll start with
the main topic so classical security
definitions for encryption if you're
familiar it's good if not it's also okay
but if you know this standard notions
indistinguishability against chosen
plaintext attacks and against chosen
ciphertext that are going DCP and ECC
they require encryption scheme to be
randomized and so why is that because
these are really strong properties they
say encryption shouldn't leak any
partial information about the message
should be very very secure and but
deterministic encryption and by
deterministic encryption I mean just
when the encryption algorithm doesn't
use any randomness so if you encrypt the
same message twice you get the same
ciphertext with deterministic encryption
and such encryption does leak
information inherently just that
information you can see when the same
message is encrypted twice and because
of this in my lectures I teach my
student that a deterministic encryption
is not good remember that it just cannot
be good it has to be randomized and in
fact it's not a problem there are tons
of efficient probably secure randomized
encryption schemes out there but in my
talk I'm going to look at deterministic
encryption which I usually say is no
good
and so why is that why am I doing this
ah there is some reason for doing this
because database researchers at Georgia
Tech brought some practical problem to
me I didn't know about before and it the
problem is for is fast search on
encrypted remotely stored data will
discuss it in more detail and it turns
out the deterministic encryption is
what's can be very useful there so there
is some reason to look at this so we'll
talk about this more other than that
there are some other reasons why it may
be interesting randomized encryption the
ciphertext has to include randomness so
it's longer than the message but
deterministic encryption in principle
can be length preserving which may be
useful again in some particular
applications late after we started this
we just discovered some relation to some
other notion which has a it's called
convergent encryption used for a totally
different problem for secure storage and
checking consistency of the storage and
just it's interesting from a theoretical
point of view and also from historical
standpoint because when public key
encryption appeared it was first
designed in the form of deterministic
encryption okay so let's look at the
main application i mentioned outsource
that databases so what's the problem so
apparently nowadays it's becoming more
and more popular for companies and
organizations to outsource data storage
and the more most importantly management
are to external service providers so
it's shipped to store but to manage it
better let it do the specialist
but this external service external
service providers do not have to be
fully trusted so I may trust them to
store and manage my data but I don't
want them to read everything and
security maybe even required by law like
for example in the case of a medical
data so what is the setting mostly in my
talk I will look at the public key
setting but at the end we will talk
about the symmetric key setting so what
is the setting we have the external
service provider database server and
anyone who knows the public key of some
distinguish receiver can submit data for
example like nurses let's imagine
pharmacists can submit some records
about some patients to the database and
then the doctor who has the secret key
should be able to query the database ask
it for specific records get them back
and decrypt and read the data so this is
the setting and we want to do it
securely okay so i guess you can must
ask me questions on your time I don't
mind yeah sure so when it's applies just
to keep the hash of the data alongside
the brain
a good point yes and we will yes I will
it's one of the solutions which was
actually of course proposed mentioned by
the database scientist right so i will
talk about it it's also it's a solution
that it will not to be it doesn't have
to be much better but it's good and
we'll discuss it at the end they're not
in the end but after yes it's there yeah
anyone can put data in let me a
nightmare of data corruption and
pollution so we of course so we in
reality we would assume the database
server would also have some kind of
authorization service on top so it but
it's an extra layer but but by anyone
women and anyone good who we want to
know oh it's not quite we'll see right
so I'm not saying it's a terribly hard
problem no but it will see some small
things you had to have to take care oh
that's a very simple setting so but it
won't and we want to do it securely ah
so in principle when this database
people told me the problem i said but
there is a good solution which was
recently proposed and it's better than
the solution which you told me with the
hash because it provides really strong
security way even though we didn't
discuss it but very good security so and
it's called encryption with keyword
search public key encryption with
keyword search apec's designed by John
Boehner and others not long ago and in
this it could be used and really good
formally analyzed security in this
solution the the user the doctor in my
example will send us a send some the
server some trap door and it's generated
using the doctor secret key only the
doctor can do it and then the server
will test this drop dough against the
data encrypted data stored in the
database and will find records matching
it really good security nothing is
licked well almost really strong
security there and I told them here is
the solution really good but they told
me and they told me are you crazy we are
not this solution requires the database
server to go over the whole database and
theoretically for me it sounds good but
they say no we have like terabytes and
terabytes of data and on each query no
way we're going to go over the whole
database that's insane and no we want to
do it fast fast meaning we want to index
the data and like it very efficiently
you better fiscal viewers every minute
but start running
you can late you're late what does it
mean you might use it on each query well
nice you can run the two ascendance in
the linear circuit anyways and be with
100 query but in aluminum bar low yeah
yeah yeah I don't wonder it fit any of
the of you but this even if it's just
one query it's a long time to go they
don't want to do it yeah I guess it's
possible but they say it's not practical
enough ah so end but I said it's a if
then if you want to do it faster it's
not possible to have this really good
security and they said it's okay fast as
important and then what's the best we
can do with this constraint and actually
database researcher so radio they try to
come up with some solutions themselves
and what you mentioned was one of the
solution and in other words and so maybe
it's good to mention what's the problem
what what's the problem if we just
encrypt all data with the randomized
encryption and sent it so what's the
problem the problem is so if this center
uses some random coins to create a
cipher text of the message and then the
client wants to locate this message and
it grips it I he's going to get a new
cipher text because it's randomized
that's very good and just there is no
way to point to this so this is just the
why randomized encryption itself is not
good and so they say okay let's just use
deterministic encryption the sender
would encrypt the message and for the
query the user just encrypt the message
and so they are the same and they can be
used as a query and the server can index
using at this deterministic encryption
and so they say we already have these
good solutions so but no formal analysis
was given which is understandable but we
want to just to study more this problem
to see whether this solution
sup dude and what security to this
provide so just formally we wanted to
look at this and so we started to look
at this and I already told you so with
deterministic solution it's indeed works
works meaning i don't know how
securities but the receiver would
encrypt something so here's the example
it sends a review or for some paper
public key of the author the title and
the review encrypted the server stores
and then the author wants to retrieve
the review sense encrypts the title so
it's the sea ciphertext coincides and we
assume the server before index that so
it has some uses some data structure to
index it and then when the query comes
it can very fast logarithmic time I
guess I like it this record can return
the other part and the author can
decrypt so it seems to work but formally
we usually we want to to analyze how
secure is it and you you just want
define some security so formally just to
understand what is it ah oops and so I
already mentioned that deterministic
encryption cannot satisfy the standard
notions of security and ecp and ECC so
we need something else and so and in
fact you may notice that since when the
public key setting if the message space
is really small you cannot have good
security at all just intuitively because
everyone can encrypt so you can exhaust
will encrypt all messages in the small
space and just see what ciphertext they
imagined so you would know so for this
you have to assume your message space is
large so and whenever we look at them
public is setting and deterministic
encryption you have to assume you're
dealing
with a large message space but still
what is the definition of security ah
cryptographers new one definition which
is suitable for deterministic encryption
for a long time it's just one wayness
just basically saying looking at the
ciphertext were randomly chosen message
you cannot recover the message so you
cannot go back if you don't know the
secret key but for these applications it
seems to week so maybe I cannot recover
the whole message but I can recover half
of the message just doesn't seem strong
enough way and it seems like it's
possible to do better so it's good to
have a better security definition
stronger one so and we try to come up
with this so at the first card let's try
just to ask that the ciphertext of a
message drawing from a large space by
looking at it and known the public key
of course no adversary efficient
adversary can compute any function of
the message ok so that's seems like a
good idea of course you always so but
you would want to say cannot compute
with good probability but some function
for example first bit of the message you
can always guess was just probability
one-half so we would just say no one no
adversary should do compute this better
than some adversary who is not given a
ciphertext even without ciphertext you
can guess the first bit of the message
so it's not a good attack but if you can
do something non trivial from the
ciphertext this is what yeah if FM is a
public key encryption of the message and
tribute is adverse
computer good meaning the site the same
phone text itself right exactly so this
is what I was going to say yeah good so
I'll just nevertheless go briefly to the
point and it's good so that's why i said
that the first try so we'll have to fix
it so and we are just trying to realize
that fix the encryption scheme so even
though we are thinking of deterministic
encryption that in the definition it
doesn't really matter it's just some
definition of security and it will cover
your solution to your proposed with the
hash so the definition is still of what
we were going to say so we consider that
versuri are which we're just / like two
parts cooperating two guys but they
don't share they can exchange
information even though they can know of
each other's algorithm and we think of
the experiment so the first guy outputs
a message drawn from a large space
should have some in entropy in it and
some string target representing this
final information they have to guess
about the message and later the other
guy will be given the cipher text of
this message and the public key and has
to guess this target information so this
is what its represented so one
experiment first guy outputs the message
and some targets some string which can
have first beat anything half of the
bits and then we encrypt give the
ciphertext to the other guy and he has
to guess this target the first guy
created and if it guesses with AIDS who
it wins this is one experiment and in
that experiment the adversary it's the
same but the adversary is given some
bogus message and it has to get some
information about total and related
message the so this is just to exclude
trivial attacks so this guy just not
given the ciphertext so it seems
reasonable but you caught me so exactly
under this which seems natural
definition no scheme is secure
regardless of whether the message space
is large or not
this target if it's a ciphertext
deterministic ciphertext is some
information which is licked and this
definition was kind of targeting hi it
says no information should be late but
it is leaked by functionality it's just
has to be licked therefore it's it
doesn't work well it's just too strong
definition for our primitive so but it
seemed good so we just try to fix it
yeah pair of players in bridge you know
playing is one player but no more we
communicate this will follow yeah yeah
before it lays down right one day yeah
but then they share some information the
one reveals one right if if it's oh but
the other pair right exactly it's very
footage it okay so I but the definition
looked good there was just one problem
and we try to fix it how to fix it well
kind of trivially we just say ah we are
not gonna give the public key to this
guy so it cannot output the ciphertext
well it's not ideal but it's the only
way we see how to fix it what it means
is that now it says the definition would
protect the data which does not depend
on the public key with it in practice
it's probably okay public keys are
usually hidden on some software no and
write so well our definition is going to
hide information about msgs not
depending on the public key that's the
only thing we could do and I think it's
still fine for most applications but
it's good to realize we cannot do better
now the previous attack does not apply
and the definition seems achievable so
that's one and in fact this is one of
the definition we call it 311 brief of
pro privacy one means just one message
in the standard notions again whether
you know them or not it doesn't really
matter it's it looks something like this
dad with three outputs messages and then
get ciphertext on head then guess has to
get something it doesn't really matter
whether the adversary asks just one
message or many messages polynomial it's
still the same and the question is it
the same for our definition to so and by
the way yeah so in under this definition
we say the definition is brief one CP
chosen plaintext attacks secure if it's
just no efficient adversary can do much
better in the first experiment than the
other but we can consider just exact
same experiment where it's not one
message but a vector of messages and the
target information represents some some
information from the whole vector it's
reasonable in the standard setting for
randomized encryption it doesn't matter
much so for simplicity you can just
consider one message here we'll see so
but first we we just do that it's just a
vector now that's several messages okay
so and we just any restrictions on the
message so you can we still going to
work with large message space this is
not going to go away so each message
which means each message is hard to
guess hyman entropy otherwise the
definition we cannot achieve it but
still there are several possibilities
and one possibility would say that each
message is hard to guess but other than
that they can be arbitrarily dependent
you can have a message x which is random
and the second message can be X plus 1
the second message can be X plus 3 it's
allowed still each message is hard to
guess and this is the definition
which we call brief CP we'll see whether
the equivalent of strong or not but you
also can consider a weaker definition
stronger restriction on the message on
the messages when we say each message
hard to guess given the others so my
previous example will we had the random
message and run the message plus one is
not it does not satisfy this restriction
because once you given X you the X plus
1 is not hard to guess right so and this
is called blog sources and in the
example for example if we consider phone
numbers you can know that some numbers
share the same prefix because they're
from the same area but even knowing that
they are dependent but still given one
it's hard to guess the other so this
would still satisfy this weaker
definition so we have these two
variations and the question so what are
the relations between these definitions
and we just started so we know what the
strongest what is equivalent and so our
results are that the definition for one
message is strictly weaker than the
strongest definition for vector of
messages and this is different from the
case from the standard encryption it's
good to know they are the result is
actually the middle one previous epfo
blog sources turns out to be equivalent
to the definition with just one message
so for simplicity we we come just style
in work with this one for blog sources
and this is going to be our strongest
one it's interesting the second result
is way more it's way harder to show them
the first one and use some ideas from
works of Doris and Smith on entropic
security and some other recent work
some French names I forgot which looked
also on entropic security it's all in
the information theoretic not
computational and symmetric key setting
and the last two works actually for the
quantum setting but the techniques are
very useful but what's important is the
result we just know how do the
definitions relate now we have the
definitions and almost I as usual so if
you know it makes sense to always
consider stronger definitions in terms
of not only chosen plaintext attack
where the adversary has some can choose
messages but also chosen ciphertext
attacks when the adversary is allowed to
see descriptions of ciphertext to its
choice chosen ciphertext in addition to
chosen plaintext and we can just make
our definition take these chosen
ciphertext into account in the standard
way just given the adversary the
decryption Oracle so we do this it's
just pretty standard and then we have
all these definitions with CCA chosen
ciphertext attack this is just a
stronger version and it it's always good
to target for this stronger chosen
ciphertext attacks and the same
relations hold so now we have
definitions it's time to look at the
constructions and first constructions
are going to be in the random Oracle
model so what is this it's the Sun it's
not real it's an idealized model which
assumed the hash functions actually
ideal objects they're just purely random
functions all parties have oracle access
to ok in this model it's not very hard
to come up with secure constructions and
one of the constructions we call it
encrypt with hash it's pretty intuitive
so we have any encryption scheme it has
randomness in it we we want
deterministic scheme so we just make the
randomness we replace it with some
deterministic function of the message
nimala hash of
the message hash the message this end
them use any randomized encryption
scheme and substitute random coins with
the hash of the message and you can
decrypt too so this may be bit better
than your solution just because
ciphertext is going to be shorter for
example for this reason because hash is
within the ciphertext but pretty much
the same idea so it's a deterministic
encryption scheme and we show that in
the random Oracle model if I assume
hashes ideal it satisfies the stronger
notion of security if the skin where
took a CPA you get briefed CPA and if
you take a ccs base scheme and also if
it satisfies some very very minor
constrain which is satisfied by all
practical scheme so it's not a big deal
you get briefed CCA scheme deterministic
skin ok so one simple construction just
ok so i'll repeat yeah so his idea was
very easy solution taken you randomize
scheme it's going to be randomized
encrypt the message Plus has the message
and append the hash and it's not
deterministic encryption but for the
application of search you will just use
hash as the tag and location you do you
do no no right so you would ever feel
that I can search on them
so you're real to the word by word in
that Josh is present ashes please well
in email in my case and I was looking an
encryption of what the infants have
filled the word one cell whatever this
is I'm looking at encryption and
indexing by that so if a ciphertext just
contains the hash in it you just look at
that yeah I don't know whether you put
it separately or not instead of the
whole ciphertext being the tag on which
you index you just use hash part and to
decrypt you use the cipher text which is
randomized doesn't make sense you have
only be right for example yeah but it's
all for exact match so far so I don't
think this is pretty much the same to me
an efficiency wise it's not that it's
better I'm just looking at but still if
I want to locate the word I just hash it
and if the server index stood by it but
it's the same okay ah so we say as long
as no ciphertext occurs with to higher
probability when encrypting any given
message and this is for randomized
encryption and it's actually seems from
looking at it it seems like it follows
from just the CPA requirement it just
seems of course actually it does not you
can have contrived skin which do not but
all practical schemes have this and it's
really easy to check for any scheme so
it's not a constraint at all another
scheme which we designed slightly more
complicated but not much it resembles if
you familiar with the standardized there
sa OU AP encryption scheme but it uses
three rounds and in terms of two rounds
so these are the hashes and this is
there sa function applied to the output
of this transform and also the
difference the RSA function does not
have to be applied to the whole message
the whole transform just the part
so variable message lengths is okay and
the result is that what we get is a
length preserving scheme the first one
was not length preserving because we
used hash into in place of the
randomness it was some extra here it can
be links preserving nothing on top and
we show that it's also satisfy the
strongest notion proof CCA in the random
Oracle model assume in one-wayness of
their RSA function okay ah so the now
let's look at the construction without
assuming this idealistic random Oracle's
and both of the schemes were first
designed I in the random Oracle model
it's very common to first whenever have
the first primitive to realize it
assuming random Oracle's it's convenient
it's not that bad but everyone realizes
it's an idealistic model it's a good
heuristic but strictly speaking proofs
of security in this model do not
guarantee security in the strongest
sense so it's always good to have
something without random Oracle's even
though again it's common without random
Oracle schemes turn to be less efficient
but still it's good to know you can do
it and there are several works which
raised concern actually they're more
than what's listed here that they can
raise concern about the sounders of the
random Oracle model you can have schemes
which are secure in it but in practice
no way but they are very contrived so we
still hope for good schemes it's okay so
it's interesting to see whether you can
do deterministic encryption in the
standard model random Oracle devoid
model and so we managed to get some
positive results but only for this week
a definition security for block sources
hi restrictions on the message space
still probably good for some
applications like social security
numbers phone numbers it is still an
open question seems to be very hard
we'll see seems to be very hard to
achieve the strongest definition
industry doubt random Oracle's will see
it will be interesting to see if it's
possible so our constructions use as
building blocks some recently introduced
primitives called alessia trap the
functions to know about one trap the
functions introduced by picker and water
in very recently the goal was different
they were looking for constructing
randomized find ECC encryption schemes
but the primitives seems to be very
useful and we will use them so let's
briefly review them so what does it mean
a lousy trap the function it's a drop
the function one way there is some trap
door with which you can invert but it
operates in two molds basically the key
generation can generate to type of the
keys so one is a normal mode invertible
hard to invert without knowing the
secret key but if you know the secret
key you can invert but they are the mode
is lossy meaning it just loses some
information about the input and you
cannot invert and the other restriction
the modes are indistinguishable if you
given this two keys which yield two
different modes you don't know what is
the case and there are several
constructions and the different
assumptions were given in that paper and
what we observe is that if you just
concern about security against chosen
plaintext attacks it's easy if you get a
lousy trap door function and if you look
at it losi mode by the way this lost
mode and invertible one it's used only
in the proofs in the reality you always
use the normal one but the sluicey mode
is very useful in the proofs so this if
you look at this low c mode and if you
if you
see that it acts as a universal hash
function there is this property it's not
quite important what it is but there is
a property it's a non cryptographic
property of the if if this Lucy Maud has
this property then immediately this
lossy trapdoor function gives you
deterministic encryption secure in the
sense brief for block sources because
it's used in the normal mode you can
decrypt its function deterministic and
you can show that it's indeed secure for
block sources or the equivalent
definition was just one message and the
proof is rather easy it just uses the
leftover hash lemma and so it's pretty
straightforward and so we'll talk wool
and the kind of web I tell you I guess I
later have a slide that the
constructions of loss eater of the
functions which were provided by picutre
and waters they satisfy this restriction
for the one of them so it has this
Universal awesome mode so it can be used
we'll discuss it but what about the
strongest security against chosen
ciphertext attacks so it's a slightly
more involved and we use the other
primitive used by these people to
construct randomized encryption scheme
so all but one job dual function is a
generalization of velocity function it
has an additional input a set of
branches or modes you can also call one
branch specify a low c function but all
other specify normal invertible
functions and again you cannot tell
which is which by given a branch you
cannot tell so it's just more slightly
more general and against several
constructions are there and so if we
have the end this is our construction of
deterministic encryption scheme it's
different from the construction of
peculiar waters which use one time
signature scheme which seemed to be hard
to Darren demise and this is how a
cipher text in our skin would
click so here we have some hash function
this is a lossy trapdoor function and
this is this all but one function and
this hash specifies a branch and you can
decrypt it's deterministic and we show
that it is secure actually it's either
brief one or pre for block sources it's
a type of this intermediate notion if
hash so this is a low c trop de function
with the universal law sub mode this is
all but one function again with
universal branch and this is a hash
function which is both Universal and
target collision resistant it's a week
on ocean than standard collision
resistance under these assumptions we
show that this is free for block sources
okay so this would general construction
what about instantiation zaz I said the
DD h decisional diffie-hellman base
construction provided by picutre waters
has universal mode so we can just plug
it in but we need a for the CCA
construction we need hash which is both
Universal and target collision resistant
to the best of our knowledge it's the
first time when these two properties are
needed together usually it's one or
another but so if we want to work with
this deed eh assumption well we found
some schemes some constructions actually
of existing hash functions and we show
that they satisfy both this properties
and we show this for two popular groups
where did eh is hard so we have the
under the DDT assumption we have
everything but this constructions of
lossy trap the functions no but one trap
the functions benton based on GD h which
were provided in the in the other paper
so they an efficient
actually bit by bit in the matrix form
not very efficient so we wanted to do
more something more efficient and but
there are the constructions for example
the head constructions of this law see
functions based on DC poly years based
encryption than other assumption but the
they didn't seem to have universal OC
modes and this is additional thing we
needed so didn't seem to work and for
that we just designed the trick to our
general construction which allows us to
avoid this additional restriction so we
just modify our construction by using a
pairwise independent but invertible hash
functions if you have this and there are
some constructions which you can have
and if you process the message first
with these hash functions then we say
that the assumptions can be we
controlled together you don't need
Universal losi modes of these two
primitives anymore and also you don't
need universality of the hash so it
seems better with the streak and we can
then we show that you can use per year
based construction from pickles of
orders but actually we improve
efficiency of it just make it even more
efficient and but funny it was
independently the exact same efficient
palea basic instructions were discovered
by rosa and sega very recently so we can
have something more efficient and it's
still not as f as close to efficiency to
random Oracle constructions but it's
actually not that bad and we have
security in the standard model without
assuming random Oracle's but it's for
block sources ok so this is about all
the main results
we did on the public key deterministic
encryption so now but as you mentioned
is you noticed i was i was going to
trick you a bit of saying the
deterministic encryption is what you
need for the search but it doesn't have
to be deterministic as so it doesn't
have to be for the same functionality of
this particular application and so this
is why we generalize what we need we
call it efficiently searchable
encryption this primitive and
deterministic encryption is just one
particular case what that satisfies it
yeah she's on the RSA encryption how do
you guarantee that you have a link for
serving mechanism because I see that I
said that's a nice feature of actually
starting the database because of the
database actually 44 if you're swimming
just cereal storage of it if you don't
have length per serving yeah talking
about rabbi today that 20 retreat
encrypted love that becomes an issue for
just the construction was deterministic
it was likes preserving hash and racine
no I the legs preserving one when the
hashing was done kind of so maybe I can
go back quickly and we'll see ok this is
the scheme so ah this is the message
real size and this is the ciphertext
real size they about the same that's my
proof so ok so if the message is really
short you cannot use just shorter SI
with because you need to have at least
thousand 24 but but then probably it's
not a big deal if you have few extra
bits right so it cannot get shorter than
there is a key but if it's longer you
just do it like this this is lengths
preserving transformation hashes on the
part of the message and they inside it
doesn't increase the size of the
if a text and you apply their receipts a
permutation used you can stay the same
size as long as it's not shorter than
the size of their sake it's just by
construction and all that the
constructions and note lengths
preserving this is the only one we had
okay efficiently searchable encryption
just a generalization we say you don't
need the terminal stick encryption we
want the same functionality so for that
we require encryption scheme to have two
functions in addition have to be defined
F and G which I used for queries and
indexing so if someone sends a cipher
text so the server will use one function
G on the cipher text in order to index
know where to like it and then whenever
the query comes in the user would use
the other function f which on the
message to compute the query and the
server will take it and go to the exact
same index so we ask this to the results
of these functions to be the same what
server can use and what the user can so
basically what sender can send and use
and the server can use and what the
receiver can use to query in the case of
deterministic encryption both of these
functions adjust safe attacks basically
this whole part in your solution which
we are coming to it's going to be just
the hash you take the same ciphertext
and hash part of it this is your
function and you just hash the message
this is the function and then coincide
doesn't have to be the the whole
ciphertext which is the same it can be a
part which can be used so but
deterministic encryption is just a
special case the same security
definition applies because in the
definition we didn't say it has to be
deterministic same security definitions
are there and your construction which
you so immediately we called encrypt and
ash you just encrypt within your
randomized scheme and append the hash
and you use it for searching and it was
proposed in the database literature but
we just confirmed that it is secure in
the random Oracle model if the hash has
this ideal property also it brings me to
one question that this scheme maybe I
overemphasized a little bit the
importance of deterministic encryption
because for the main application we see
that it's the hash what's needed in the
random Oracle model no problem in the
standard model so it makes sense to
design not the whole deterministic
encryption scheme but just the hash
which has South so what properties so
that the whole scheme satisfy our
definitions so we see that we didn't
state it anywhere but it seems fine that
full block sources just universal hash
function and the leftover hash lemma
would work still a big open question not
much well seems easier than encryption
but still seems to be very hard to
design a hash secure in the strongest
sense still open question not for block
sources I don't know the solution i know
several people are trying no results of
i will seep good so i have oh just one
small point here that if you use encrypt
and hash construction then you can have
some efficiency security trade-off
because if you don't like that you can
see that where the equal messages are in
the database you can try to decrease the
output of the hash so have some
collisions actually there so several
plaintext will map to the same
ciphertext the server wouldn't be able
to tell it will count with the price of
having more
all positives right on each query silver
server will return more answers may be
preferable in some applications and so
just this trade-off you may have to
limit the output of the hash and I have
a few minutes and I'll uh I just want to
tell you a little bit about the
symmetric key setting and more flexible
queries so deterministic encryption and
the symmetric is setting we treated it
to our things a bit easier there so we
have the definition and we because
things I easy we'll start the definition
not only provide privacy but also
provide the things icity and finding the
definition is also not that complicated
so we did this our construction what we
have just a few interested asked to
compute a Mac of the message this is
basically in place of the hash we used
in the public key setting and most max a
PRF so it's a good it's a pseudo-random
function and then we use this tag this
Mac as the IV for the CBC encryption
mode and surprisingly it's the same
construction which was used for
independently for totally different I
application which is called key rep by
rogue away and shrimpton ah ok yeah so
this is very briefly about the symmetric
key setting so when we did it we were
kind of happy with ourselves and for
example the somatic say solution we
presented at the database conference we
thought they would like it but they said
okay but it's only exact match it's ball
so we want to do all types of queries we
want to do minimum maximum range queries
average do it the stool it's not enough
okay one thing at a time so we
yep and so what they're particularly
interested about and again they are
trying to do it themselves they want to
do range queries so you have your data
now returned with the records which
contains fo text encryptions of from 100
to 300 something like that and again
they had several ideas and two ideas
actually one is I don't not sure if it's
their name but the idea if it's it is
prefix preserving encryption and imagine
your plain text and numbers and in the
binary form so they encrypt everything
bit by bit and they have the property
that and it's kind of deterministic
right so if two messages start with the
same prefix the ciphertext will also
start with the same prefix that's why
I'll call it's perfect preserving and
they say you can express a range a set
of numbers sometimes with just the
minimum set of prefixes right so and
then basically how it's called star then
whatever after so this prefix and the
rest can be anything and this prefix and
you can express a range like this they
suggested to use it to answering range
queries the other suggestion was to use
or the preserving encryption meaning if
two plain text n order one smaller than
the other the shoot the same should hold
in the safe attack so you can sort the
ciphertext and that's all and then if
it's deterministic you just encrypt the
range and the database will return
everything in between they decide they
design something I looked at it my
student looked at it it doesn't make any
sense so I cannot parse it so I and I
will know I even though I told them it
doesn't make sense they say it must make
sense because it was published in our
best
database conference and I said no they
say it must it's very good yeah almost
identical to one cup our code books
which I believe in the 19th century then
you have to crack okay actually so maybe
you can notice that it's easy to crack
so if you if you and the public key
setting okay if its public if you can
encrypt everything yourself it's
deterministic or the preserving it
doesn't make any sense if you have some
ciphertext you take some message
encrypted if its larger you go here
encrypt it and a kind of you will
converge to the message so i don't know
how can it make sense but they were
probably talking about symmetric you're
setting where it's not right it seems to
me that it can make some sense it's not
very strong security but something can
be there right so at least it's not
everything is obviously insecure you can
have some security it not totally
obvious but it has been broken
uncharitable young but in what what
scheme one time comic books can be
notoriously weak sense but what does not
say cops explain words and the Cobras
are the same order so if you know that
if you know that is you so you find a
code word you know I this must be before
Ali Baba and after Ali Baba and default
bug that right because of alphabetic
order right oh well it's your so you
probably will one thing is that you
idiot if you think about you the
ciphertext space definitely has to be
way larger than the message space it's
not the case in your skin so if its way
larger these simple things do not
necessarily hold reserving a better how
large it is I if I know the good
or two messages I know which messages
between the Midwest not go between and
the rock but you look at the ciphertext
so and they can be way further apart so
you know I think it may make sense so
that's what we're looking at now so I
don't have all the results but we are
trying to define security scene can you
have some security and then trying to
find the schemes maybe maybe we can
discuss I'll tell you our scheme will
try to crack it that will be first test
okay it can be interesting and also
prefix preserving scheme we also had
something which may be more efficient
that what they had but it seems less
interesting to me because when used for
range queries that actually can reveal
some information for some ranges just
looking at the ciphertext you can know
for example for bit by bit encryption so
I'm not sure how useful it is but all
the preserving encryption seems
interesting to me seems to make some
sense so we can discuss it actually
there are some ideas here and it
actually it's interesting it's the first
time I do something when the solution
has so little with scriptor it's just
some probability theory some
distributions and just the question of
how to efficiently sample a random order
preserving function we'll see and that's
it so on time so studied some security
definitions for deterministic and
efficiently searchable encryption showed
some relations between them provided
construction in the random Oracle model
in the strongest sense and some less
efficient construction but in the
standard model for slightly weaker
definition so discuss this more general
primitive efficiently searchable
encryption several
one constructions there and discuss
symmetric key setting and more flexible
queries thank you thanks more questions
in the additionally cervical encryption
don't you need the fact that that at
Madeira both non-invertible pregnant
oh it it will bro it is probably implied
by the security notion but this is just
the minimum syntax you need just to have
functionality but then you look at the
security definition so most probably yes
if it's not satisfied it will not be
satisfied but it had nothing to do with
the security at that time it's just what
do you need to do search and then you
later look at whether secure it or not
yeah this may be a very unfair question
but it seems that when naively the
thesis search Rodimus encryption our we
all of us broke in our first two years
when you learn our first language where
is the difference and why is any data
music encryption stronger than what a
two year to year or beta can break and
so what does it that can break I'm not
quite sure sir knowing no language right
right and we all managed by listening
around right not two years to learn one
language rather the gold are in trouble
right why is the Terminator encryption
any stronger the code to your own baby
break
and not all true vertical the job of
food NSA the the message space is large
it's not possible to remember all and
you cannot go back you just don't
remember all the mappings it's a you're
lost you can break and remember all the
messages David I don't know but do we
miss learn more than this they here they
actually did but here you need English
or German or but there you punch but
they're your size right here you you you
hear you hear way less than what you
asked to crack so maybe your circle the
full message which must be way longer
than a telephone no because telephone
numbers are just answering any of them I
thought most servers are on you know
telephone numbers all galaxies number
you just what you're saying is that in
practice you will not so our requirement
that the message spaces will very large
lot of hymen entropy in reality yeah so
even probably my name will be you can
alexandra is not that bad so right yeah
that's a good point well you know I say
it's a good point so what it says that
look if you want to have if they just
want to have faster shin they say
whatever the best security that's the
best security it's not very good the
point is if you don't have a large
message space and probably you don't
have it well then we cannot help you
then you have to do more work on
searching if you want high security
absolutely yeah that's yeah
the grocery never sees the public he
physically not baby it was trying to
learn Lane some critical piece of
information he never gets to see I I
somehow don't think this is the reason
it's probably more to the difference but
even without it not sure one of their
noses can see them there are the one can
yes who who is asked to actually use and
that guy can encrypt everything by
itself with the public is so it's not
really that thing you see also you have
no traffic analysis just knowing when a
query is sent like the day Warren
Buffett has a heart attack you know the
stock market clear that we love about
your hand away good question so we
actually didn't analyze the whole sick
like somehow it was security of the
primitive how it's used for example the
server would know what it finds right
yeah so all these things somehow will be
you on tower thing right they have to be
treated additionally but that's true
yeah there are things like that yeah
all right
you